de quoi voulez pas un petit cochon jade
était le petit cochon on vient de le
voir vous avez refusé de le montrer non
non non non on l'a vu il est n 18
non mais non il n'y a eu qu'un petit
cochon ya six ans le plateau désormais
je vous dis lui n'a été montrée alors
comme les images pour qu'on le montrera
parce qu'il ya des règles en télévision
des acteurs on est en direct au conte la
montre au début et vous savez on peut
pas montrer comme ça des animaux morts
il ya des enfants qui nous regardent il
ya déjà des parents aussi ya des noms
ici c'est des images un peu choquant et
on ne peut pas montrer toutes les images
il ya le csa christine kelly holmes est
parti et je pense c'est une image et
qu'on ne peut pas montrer qu'il me
rappelle très bien de ce moment là on
l'a on a dit qu'on ne faisait pas d'un
gros plan parce que ça avait surpris
tout le monde c'était un bon alors je
veux dire alors allez-y analystes ce qui
est choquant c'est surtout une tribu bon
c'est quoi ce qui ce qui attend les
vitrines de la résistance animalistes
avons fait une promesse à ce petit
porcelet qui ne serait pas morte pour
rien balances ton post n'est ce pas
alors oui balancer maintenant votre
poste l'acte neufs commence maintenant
plus jamais les ports ne seront balancés
action directe de justice maintenant sur
boucherie absolution alors là vous êtes
en eux en direct
[Applaudissements]
addai j'ai rien contre vous et je
comprends tout à fait votre caisse avait
juste anaïs là on a l'impression que
vous donnez des codes on dirait qu'on va
la sélectionnée elle est passionnée elle
est très émue je sais écouter la ce
qu'elle dit est important il n'est pour
une boîte toujours d'accord avec tout ce
qu'elle dit est gardée secrète et un
mort c'est un peu paradoxal poids alors
comme ça
anaïs alesi nom m'a dit que votre vote
série potes notre message est important
mais anna bree en droit que les
téléspectateurs ne comprennent ni zip
analyse par les libres maintenant vous
êtes le leur et sage le message est très
très clair le message est très très
clair à nos élus action to direct
maintenant l'action illégale sur
boucherie absolution maintenant
absolution maintenant sur le facebook
boucherie abolition actions illégales
insurrection maintenant des obus
sensationnel en fait maintenant
résistance animalistes en actions
maintenant jusqu'à l'abolition
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
voilà eurent un petit événement avec
cette jeune fille anaïs qui est voilà
qui fait partie d'un mouvement vegan il
voulait faire une action en direct
qu'ils ont filmée sur facebook c'est
aller dans un abattoir pour aller donc
kidnappé un cochon voilà elle l était
pas du tout violent de sachez le elle
est là juste elle voulait juste montrer
une pour une
voilà une peau car tout voilà une ado
qu'elle peut revenir anaïs montrer votre
truc
voilà juste et dites nous ce que vous
voulez faire boucherie abolition yahoo
voilà c'était sur facebook parce que
voulait lancer un appel sur un facebook
live c'est ça je voulais je vous tienne
votre micro
voilà merci il n'y a rien de violence à
celle parce que c'est vrai que ça a été
un petit peu rapide et voilà on a cru
qu'anaïs voulais m'attaquer mais anaïs
n'était pas du tout là dedans je vois là
elle voulait juste me protéger un peu
plus son millionnaire venez venez
l'analyse comme ça qu'on voit bien votre
truc est donc dit waouw réplique cours
alors il s'est tout simplement je ne
suis pas là pour débattre on ne
sensibilisent part à l'holocauste c'est
pas pour contre le massacre coup contre
tuer pour contre le viol va pas comparer
c'est votre définition de low cost alors
exactement cette année elle qui nous
sont si occupés
si on fait ce que j'aimerais bien qu'on
arrête avec ces mots ou est-ce qu'il ya
des gens vraiment qu'ils peuvent pas
qu'ils exportent ans de ça c'est très
grave et on peut pas faire cet amalgame
là voilà je vous dis je suis ce qu'on
dit en premier bien sûr que la
comparaison
cette comparaison c'est pas nous qui l'
abandon au oui non mais ils font ça
vient comme m2 ça a été écrit dans un
livre collectif va rester que oui ben
justement votre combat voilà je vous dis
je peux le comprendre je comprends aussi
été débouchées qui a envie de travailler
mais juste aller voilà c'est luce qui a
des mots qui peuvent choquer surtout en
direct latam rideau et à sauver le monde
en sauvant les animaux dans le milliard
de morts
encore le 2 milliard de morts chaque
année
alors qu'elle est bonne et anaïs moi je
vous laisse la parole parce que je
laisse la parole à tout le monde ici
soyez faune islam est tranquille dont je
me laisserais la parole le temps qu'il
faut j'ai fait passer votre message et
dites moi ce qui se passe comme je
voulais dit c'est très simple on ne
corps une fois on ne sensibilisent pas
aux massacres d'accord un d'être
innocent qu'on fait naître pour tuer on
ne sensibilisent pas l'holocauste
ce débat non non ce débat non eddehbi
voilà bon bah merci
elle a fait passer son message merci
anaïs voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
pas faire ce genre de comparaison est
vraiment je sais c'est pourquoi par la
voix ou de l'avoir fait d'accord avec
vous